hi my name is James I'm 20 years old and
I'm from Seattle Washington I've been a
screenwriter for roughly three years now
I've worked on a few short films smells
really a music video and I've written a
few pilots for fun my current script is
a 60-minute drama it's a pilot for a
miniseries or hopefully to the three
season show I started writing it roughly
a year ago and I've finished its fourth
draft just last week actually um I'm
writing it because I believe it will one
day inspire hopefully save another
person's life I mean that sounds kind of
pretentious but that's honestly why I'm
writing it it's this the show delves
deep into depression mental illness and
suicide in teen's life roughly 16 to 20
oh ah my goal for it is to get it may
just to get it put out there and that's
also another reason why I'm not quitting
on it I I really believe that it will
hopefully touch Lee somebody's life out
there and inspire them or you know
inspire somebody else to help somebody
that they know that suffers from you
know those things that I mentioned um my
biggest thing that I've learned from
screenwriting has to be deleting I love
deleting I've made some of my best stuff
actually from just deleting and deleting
deleting deleting my recent short film
was actually supposed to be a two-hour
film and it now it sits at what 35
minutes and it's amazing really um not
to screenplay but the mold screenplays
good but deleting I mean when do I right
well it really depends I mean I never I
never force myself to write
um it I it's garbage just comes out when
I try to just force myself to write um I
find usually when I am really tired or
what is it when when I actually the
field most inspired when I'm super tired
or when I've read something really bad
and I just get this urge to write the
best that I can that's that's really it
really um let's see my screen writing
goals whoo my screenwriting goal is to
be a show runner who I want to be a show
honor want to be that guy in charge that
fixes every script to make sure that's
the best and I want to hopefully change
TV and make sure that everything that
goes out is the best just the best or i
want to be a screen door script doctor
and be the guy that Studios call and
they're like our scripts bed can you fix
it I want to be that guy I'm gonna be
that guy that shows up and just fixes it
makes it the best thing that you've ever
seen or ever read but let's see what
else we got here um finally see a story
for my screen writing career well
actually recently i just finished
wrapping up writing a short film for
this crew that I met out east if it's a
story about well I don't really want to
give the story too much of the story
away essentially it's about this
transgender teen who finds the stranger
who essentially changes his look there
live their life I should say and it's
just it it's so crazy writing somebody
else's life through your eyes and it's
just it's just incredible that's
probably not really that interesting to
some people but yeah
yeah so yeah bye